Transformers rise of the Beast
introduces a new set of robots in
Disguise but it takes place in the 1990s
well before the entries in the series
directed by Michael Bay so why didn't
the Autobots ever mention their powers
the Maximus spoilers for Rise of the
beasts ahead the continuity of the
live-action Transformers films has
always been pretty sketchy even within
the five directed by Michael Bay 2018's
Bumblebee which took place in 1987
ostensibly functions as a soft reboot of
the franchise but it's also a prequel
showing what bumblebee was up to before
he met Sam Witwicky in the first
Transformers movie you talk to the radio
[Applause]
you're wonderful
right to the Beast supposedly takes
place within this same timeline were the
previous cinematic installment being
directly referenced when Optimus Prime
mentions how Bumblebee has already made
friends with humans connecting the two
most recent Transformers movies with
Michael Bay's entries in the franchise
can prove Troublesome especially now
that the maximals have been introduced
they've been on Earth for a long time
and after the climactic battle it's
assumed they're still around probably
continuing to be based in Peru so if
rise of the Beast leads into Bay films
it raises the question of why the
maximals didn't help out during all of
those potential world ending events the
maximals are even the ones who have to
teach Optimus Prime to work alongside
the humans so they likely have just as
much of an interest in protecting
Humanity if not more why did they remain
in hiding then after the good guys
succeed in destroying the transwarp key
and preventing Unicron from coming to
Earth everyone seemingly goes their
separate ways the Autobots are accepting
of humanity while the human characters
are changed for the better it's unclear
what exactly the maximals get up to but
presumably they go back to living in the
Peruvian jungle with the indigenous
tribe they befriended it's
understandable that they don't
necessarily want to be bothered with
every little thing but the Michael Bay
Transformers movies have some
significant threats that put the entire
world in Jeopardy it's unclear why the
Autobots wouldn't call on them again to
help them to fight off the Decepticons
maybe another Factor at play here though
no one can seem to Bumblebee and Rise of
the base of recalls to the Bay film
straight at reboot some things are
seemingly Canon Megatron for example
wasn't in bumblebee or rise of the Beast
because the other entries established he
was frozen during those decades
bumblebee director Travis Knight even
told The Hollywood Reporter he couldn't
use Megatron in his film for that reason
on the other hand there's a lot that's
seemingly being retconned in the new
Transformers movies for one 2017's the
last night established how Unicron was
actually Earth with its horns protruding
out to the planet's surface rides the
Beast however shows unicorn as a
completely separate entity the new movie
also has a final scene where Noah is
recruited by GI Joe potentially setting
up a crossover event between the two
Hasbro franchises and this would only
open up more questions as to how the
movies fit in with bass it's possible
the explanation for why the maximals
aren't in any other Transformers movie
is that these new ones take place in a
different timeline if Paramount does
want to keep everything Under One Roof
the maximal's exclusion could be
explained in a future installment
perhaps a sacrifice their lives
valiantly to protect Earth or maybe they
find a way off the planet at the end of
the day these are movies about robot
aliens that turn into cars so maybe it's
best not to think too hard about it
[Music]